[Music]
after you won you tweeted this out which
I absolutely love actually mentioned on
my show
I wish the Sochi medals were made out of
bacon however that actually said that
some of the day you tweeted that out I
repeat it to the audience and everybody
cheered really if there's one thing
Americans can all get behind besides a
gold medal it's bait so here's what we
did we had the good people at God Shaw's
quality meats in Pennsylvania make your
wish come true
this is quality bacon
[Applause]
I
yeah yeah it's supposed to be good ideas
good
[Applause]
okay this one we just made all your
dreams come that was really cool man
that was destroyed though got nothing
left of it really you know what I'll get
you another one we got to get another
one what all sad when you saw it was
mostly gun hey man
that harsh my mellow but actually I
cannot thank you enough for stopping by
for changing me completely yeah this is
the cone and I was always meant and is
matter lychee way better and I'm so
proud of you and all of us are thank you
thank you
[Applause]